en el vídeo anterior cuando lanzamos
algo en el aire encontramos sus
componentes horizontal y vertical y de
este vector velocidad con su componente
vertical encontramos cuánto tiempo tardó
el objeto en el aire y después usamos
ese tiempo para calcular qué distancia
se desplazó el objeto antes de volver a
caer al suelo teniendo una velocidad
horizontal constante lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es rehacer parte de este
problema de una manera un poquito más
complicada pero a la vez es una forma
más poderosa y la usaremos en futuros
vídeos en el vídeo anterior para
calcular cuánto tiempo estaba el objeto
en el aire lo que hicimos fue ver que
iniciábamos y terminábamos en la misma
elevación y la velocidad vertical que
tenemos aquí va a ser la misma velocidad
pero en dirección opuesta que tendremos
acá y usamos esta lógica para calcular
el cambio en velocidad y después usamos
esto el cambio en velocidad y la
aceleración constante debida a la fuerza
de gravedad de un objeto en caída libre
para calcular nuestro tiempo en el aire
fue algo bastante sencillo lo que vamos
hacer ahora es encontrar una fórmula que
no sea útil para otro tipo de problemas
y siempre me gusta deducir las fórmulas
en lugar de memorizar las pero antes de
continuar tenemos que tener en mente que
nuestra velocidad vertical fue de 5
metros por segundo al menos lo que
calculamos en el vídeo anterior y
teniendo en cuenta esta velocidad
vertical vamos a ver cuánto tiempo
permanece esto en el aire hacemos un
poco de espacio
así que nuestra velocidad vertical el
componente vertical de mi velocidad va a
ser igual a 5 metros por segundo este es
el dato del vídeo anterior y también
recordemos que nuestra convención cuando
tratamos con vectores de una dimensión y
este es un vector en una dimensión es
vertical va hacia arriba o hacia abajo
positivo significa arriba negativo
significa abajo como dirección cuando
trabajamos con la dirección en x con la
componente horizontal el positivo nos
indica que va hacia la derecha y el
símbolo negativo nos indica que va a la
izquierda como podemos calcular que
tanto tiempo permanece este objeto en el
aire recuerda
el desplazamiento y eso funciona cuando
trabajamos con una dimensión el
desplazamiento es igual a nuestra
velocidad promedio promedio
x el cambio en el tiempo el rango de
tiempo que permanece el objeto en el
aire y cuál es nuestra velocidad
promedio si suponemos que tenemos una
aceleración constante esta velocidad
promedio va a ser mi velocidad inicial
más la velocidad final todo esto entre 2
es la media aritmética de nuestra
velocidad inicial y nuestra velocidad
final y multiplicaremos esto por el
cambio en el tiempo ya que será igual
nuestra velocidad final bueno esta
velocidad final la voy a escribir por
acá nuestra velocidad final va a ser
igual a nuestra velocidad inicial más la
aceleración multiplicada por el cambio
en el tiempo por cuánto tiempo ha
transcurrido este de aquí es nuestra
velocidad final así que sustituyamos
esto de vuelta aquí bueno vamos a tener
entonces nuestra velocidad inicial esto
de aquí y ahora vamos a sustituir
nuestra velocidad final que es esto de
acá
así que esto se suma a nuestra velocidad
inicial más la aceleración por el cambio
en el tiempo y todo esto dividido entre
2 y además todo esto está multiplicado
por el tiempo transcurrido esto es
nuestro desplazamiento vamos a
simplificar esto estos 2 b y van a ser
igual a 2 b y 2 veces nuestra velocidad
inicial así que esta expresión de acá la
simplificamos como 2 por b entre 2 igual
a b y nuestra velocidad inicial voy a
escribir todo esto aquí y al final lo
multiplicaré por el cambio en el tiempo
es esto más la aceleración por el cambio
en el tiempo
todo esto dividido entre 2 y aquí me
quedo muy por afuera
este paréntesis todo esto va a estar
multiplicado por el cambio en el tiempo
o el tiempo transcurrido y este es
nuestro desplazamiento total ya casi
terminamos y si ustedes están
presionados por resolver un examen no es
descabellado pensar que ustedes
memoricen esto en lugar de desarrollarlo
para encontrar esta fórmula pero si
quiero que se den cuenta de que todas
estas fórmulas vienen de principios
básicos del sentido común y ustedes
pueden ser capaces de inferir les aunque
es bueno memorizarlo si estamos
presionados por realizar algún examen si
multiplicamos todo esto por nuestra del
tate nos va a quedar que el
desplazamiento es igual a nuestra
velocidad inicial por delta t nuestro
cambio en el tiempo más aceleración por
delta t por el cambio en el tiempo por
el cambio en el tiempo va a ser igual
nuestra aceleración
entre 2 y aquí tenemos cambiar el tiempo
por el cambio en el tiempo así que nos
va a quedar esto por cambio en el tiempo
al cuadrado y esta fórmula le encuentran
en varios libros de física pero como les
digo no es necesario memorizar la
ustedes pueden inferir la con los
conceptos básicos que ya conocen del
desplazamiento es igual a la velocidad
promedio por el cambio en el tiempo cuál
es la velocidad promedio cuál es nuestra
velocidad final qué es velocidad inicial
más aceleración por el cambio en el
tiempo y obtenemos esta expresión de
aquí hice esto para encontrar cuánto
tiempo permanecerá nuestro objeto en el
aire como lo encontraremos para nuestro
ejemplo en particular o para nuestro
problema en particular conocemos nuestra
velocidad inicial al menos el componente
vertical y todo esto tiene que ver con
el componente vertical de nuestra
velocidad también conocemos la
aceleración debida a la gravedad y aquí
nos hace falta conocer cuál es el
desplazamiento que va a ocurrir desde
que se lance el objeto hasta que cae y
quizá
esto no sea tan intuitivo de calcular
pero la idea que aquí el desplazamiento
va a ser igual a cero porque es esto
bueno va a haber dos momentos en los que
nuestro desplazamiento va a ser cero en
el tiempo cero nuestro proyecto aún no
ha sido lanzado así que no tiene
desplazamiento hacia arriba por lo que
no hay componente vertical de su
velocidad y el segundo momento es cuando
el proyectil cae y toca el suelo aquí
tampoco haber componente vertical porque
ya habrá tocado el suelo y estará
detenido así que si dejamos nuestro
desplazamiento en cero vamos a tener dos
respuestas posibles a esta solución y
una de esas respuestas deberá tener un
componente de tiempo diferente de cero y
ese es el que nos va a interesar porque
ese es el tiempo en el que damos contra
el suelo no el tiempo desde que lanzamos
el objeto así que apliquemos esto
tenemos que nuestro desplazamiento es
cero y esto va a ser igual a nuestra
velocidad inicial que es nuestra
componente vertical de la velocidad y es
5 no voy a escribir las unidades para
ahorrar un poco de espacio 5 metros por
segundo hacia arriba
eso lo multiplicamos por el cambio en el
tiempo el cambio en el tiempo más
bueno cuál es nuestra aceleración
nuestra convención dice que si la
dirección en ese caso de la aceleración
es hacia abajo usaremos el signo
negativo así que en este caso la
aceleración es menos 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado dividimos eso entre
2 vamos a escribirlo
de esta manera finalmente aquí no es un
más es un menos 9.8 tampoco escribo las
unidades para ahorrar espacio entre dos
por el cambio en el tiempo al cuadrado
que lo puedo poner por claridad así por
suerte para nosotros esto no es difícil
de resolver no vamos a tener que usar la
cuadrática para encontrar las soluciones
a esta ecuación podemos factorizar del
tate de manera que es cero va a ser
igual a delta t por 5 menos 9.8 entre 2
es igual a 4.9 por delta
nuestro cambio en el tiempo y aquí no
escribí latte aquí tenemos dos
soluciones dos valores para delta t que
nos dan como resultado un cero uno de
ellos es que el cambio del tiempo se
hace es decir no haya transcurrido
tiempo si tenemos cero pues esto de aquí
no importa porque lo multiplicamos va a
ser cero pero no es la solución que nos
interesa así que esta es una posible
solución pero no es la que nos interesa
de todas maneras la escribimos de manera
que una solución es que delta te sea
igual a cero y la otra solución es que
toda esta parte de aquí sea cero cuando
tenemos dos factores cuyo resultado es
cero al multiplicarse entonces con
cualquiera de estos dos que sea cero
vamos a tener este resultado así que
tenemos cinco menos 4.9 del tate igual a
cero sumamos 4.9 del tate en ambos lados
de esta ecuación y nos va a quedar que 5
es igual a 4.9 por delta t y ahora
dividimos ambos lados entre 4.9
s / 4.9 esto / 4.9 esto se cancelan y ya
tendremos el tiempo transcurrido del
tate va a ser igual a 5 / 4.9 va a ser 5
/ 4.9 igual a 1.020 4 lo redondeamos a
1.02 segundos nuevamente tuvimos el
mismo resultado si recordamos 1.02
segundos es lo mismo que obtuvimos en el
vídeo anterior esto de aquí sólo usamos
un método diferente una de las cosas
divertidas de la física es que mientras
ustedes hagan sus cálculos de manera
lógica y consistente hay muchas formas
de obtener la misma respuesta pero
siempre debe ser la misma respuesta sino
por ahí algo hicimos mal